well to me it's worse than them dying
I'm saying like if they died you know
there's no possible if you get any more
time with them you know that like no
time's being wasted you're forced to
have closure Grayson and Savannah
Chrisley not holding back about their
mom and dad living behind bars I have
raised thanking children right and so
after that I'm blessed the reality stars
open up in her unlocked podcast this
comes as Savannah continues to parent
both Grayson and their little sister
Chloe one thing that I appreciate from
you and love you so much for was you
said like hey you're doing a really good
job like I know it may feel like you're
not but like you're a kid raising two
kids yeah that is very accurate any
family who faces a loved one going to
prison it's a very difficult challenge
but they're strong they're faithful well
to me it's worse than them dying because
they're here but they're not here so
like it's just you don't get to time
that's being wasted at least like I'm
saying like if they died you know
there's no possible if you get any more
time with them you know that like no
time's being waste did raisins feelings
Echo what Savannah confessed in January
soon after Todd and Julie surrendered to
prison we made a commitment that we were
not going to give up beginning their
combined 19-year sentence my parents are
gone
um and it's tough my dad's fine absolute
best friend and I don't just get to pick
up the phone and call him and that's
what I mean by like it feels like a slow
death because in in a way it is grief
because I'm grieving
my normal I'm grieving the loss of my
parents and what I know I've never seen
two people my parents be so steadfast in
their faith in the end the truth will
prevail may get harder before it gets
easier but we have faith I feel like we
are at a stage of our life where we need
to find where we're going to settle I
want Grayson to be settled the last few
years he's at home before he goes to
college racing was just eight years old
when his family's reality series took
off listen no one's life is laughter all
the time we wish it were but you know we
have a lot of real moments I mean it's
reality television Flash Forward to 2023
he's 17 and the Chrisleys have another
docu-series lined up which will focus on
the Family's whole new reality the new
shows is me Savannah and the rest of the
people in my family how we're navigating
it together as a family my dad's one of
the smartest human beings that I've ever
met so when I do get to see him and talk
to him yeah I tell him about everything
get his his input and he loves to see us
win he's like I mean yeah yeah he was
like run it through the roof what do you
know about this documentary and the
message that the Chrisley family wants
to now show the world I I can just tell
you there is there is a story there
um about what they've been through the
past year or two that hasn't been told
[Music]
foreign